Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning Deshita!
Ruffians!
Today, it's the 95th morning!
The 95th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today on the 5th episode.
The 5th?
On the 5th episode to 100.
Sound like sense?
BAU BAU!
B
Right, and to explain FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday, what?
I'm Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Oh, you missed episode 94.
What do you mean you missed episode 94?
Where the BAU BAU gone gone?
There's a secret ruffian.
You can go watch it on YouTube.
If you search up FUWAMOCO channel.
I just heard this, I don't know.
Whenever Mococo hi.
What do you mean Moco-chan?
You were there for the 94th episode.
Missed episode 94, but not Mococo.
What?
Oh, like I missed episode 94, I didn't miss Moco-chan.
Like that?
I don't think that's what they were saying.
You sure?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
It's only been a little bit since we saw you last, right Moco-chan?
I guess you didn't miss me then, huh?
BAU BAU.
Well, I've got bad news for you.
Like, really bad news or are you just saying that because bad news?
It's a bit dangerous.
It's been a Pero Sighting.
Pero is dangerous.
Where was he seen now?
De-den.
That's so Brazil and I guess
The Great Perroccino.
Like I said, it's a bit dangerous.
Yeah.
This looks like maybe the start to an intense battle for the history book.
I don't know though, are they actually gonna fight it out there?
You know, it sort of looks like, you know, maybe they're just happy to have met up?
You know?
Oh, hey Fubucilla.
Maybe they're just ready to bully and smack around Mt.
Fuji.
I don't know, I don't think they can do that.
That's not right.
That's Malfuji.
Malfuji!
Don't bully Malfuji.
You look at it, awe at it.
His beauty and the power.
Don't bully.
Don't bully nicely.
See Malfuji there.
It's so clear!
So crisp!
You know, Mouth Fuji is just... It's so breathtaking, especially on like the clearest day.
While FubuZilla here and Pero... They don't compare.
No matter how big they are.
They don't compare!
They don't.
Yeah, and, uh, maybe, you know, maybe they're like, ah, Mount Fuji's pretty awesome.
Hai!
Nah, it's okay.
Maybe they went and decided to go bully something else.
What?
Yeah, like, Tokyo Tower.
Hai!
Yeah, you know, Tokyo Tower's not as tall as Sky Tree.
Yeah.
Tokyo Tower is a little bit bullyable, no?
BAU BAU!
I hope you're all able to enjoy Mt.
Fuji in peace.
BAU BAU!
I like Tokyo Tower.
If I had to say if I like Tokyo Tower or Sky-Chi better, I'd say Tokyo Tower.
Really?
But Sky-Chi has the marble.
Soramachi.
BAU BAU!
BAU
Ruffians!
We're sure you heard about it, but... Marine-Senchou-Senpai did it again!
She just released an amazing, brand new, original song together with Kobo-senpai.
And of course, in the true Senchou style, it's fully animated.
Did you see it?
Right!
It's amazing.
The song is called "III".
I I I!
Super hot and spicy dance number.
The song is fire, right?
Yeah, it's so trendy, right?
It makes you want to take a 30 second vertical dance video and upload it online, right?
Moco-chan, that's kind of stupid.
Do you have any kind of plans?
No!
I just thought it looked sort of fun.
I don't know, it's a very different feeling and style from Marine-senpai's previous original song, Shinkiro, together with Gura-senpai!
I really like III, but I'm also really really fond of EDC pop and city pop.
I don't know, I just can't help but love Shinkiro so much.
I love the difference between the two!
I listen to Shinkiro non-stop on the way to Japan.
It's really precious to me too now.
Ruffians, you know, when the time comes that you want to maybe spice things up and dance the night away, definitely put on III, okay?
Yeah, please check it out, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Are you following us on Twitter?
Are you?
Good question.
Sometimes I see Ruffians tweeting, FUWAMOCO's so cute!
And then I go to see if they're following us and they're not.
What's with that, Ruffians?
Hi!
Right!
I've been watching FUWAMOCO for hours!
Look for the tweet, not FUWAMOCO.
Huh?
We were too busy watching, we forgot.
That's what I think.
Why are you following us?
You don't use Twitter, that's okay.
You're following us here, right?
You subscribe to us here, right?
Right!
But if you're following us on Twitter, you might have seen, but we finished all our signing for our birthday
Yeah!
The postcards!
You know, you might have thought that we did them all that day.
We've actually been working on them over the last month together.
It took us a good while, but we put a lot of care and love into each and every one of them.
We kept thinking about how happy you'd be once you get yours.
It made us work really hard.
I kind of would do my signature and be like, aaaah, these are touching, and aaaah.
Yeah.
But I know that I kind of saw some ruffians who were wondering if maybe some have been sneezed on.
Moco-chan.
I can't deny that I do sneeze quite a bit while doing them.
This is normal for me, you know?
So, my Ruffians!
If you're able to get your paws on the limited edition postcard, maybe you guys might have, uh, something a bit extra to it?
Hopefully they smell nice!
We're also being watched over by the Ruffian plushies while we're singing too!
They're so nice!
Big, and comfy, and huggable, and soft!
It's hard, you know.
The chest are so fluffy.
Fluffy.
Yeah.
Please look forward to our birthday, my chinchinyo, okay, ruffians?
Yeah!
We're really excited for our puppies to reach us soon.
Are they still available to buy?
Unfortunately, it was limited for only a month after our birthday.
But...
Hopefully there'll be more exciting FUWAMOCO merch to come in the future, so we'll make sure to let you know that, okay?
I think you know us, but we really like heroes and mercenaries, so... We hope you'll be excited, okay, Ruffians?
We wanna make nice stuff for you, okay?
BAU BAU!
Exciting!
Right!
Moco-chan and I were very, uh...
We like our pens.
Raise the pens to make the best domestic picture possible.
Sometimes I get the ink everywhere.
Yeah.
No good.
This one's discard.
Yeah.
No good.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I was wondering, have you been a little bit confused at the end of our streams recently?
Maybe.
Has there been something maybe puzzling you a little bit?
This may be... Always!
Always!
Always?
What does that mean?
We're always confused, huh?
Huh?
What are we doing to confuse you that much, huh?
The idea of things ending is confusing?
That must be it, huh?
It's confusing when it ends, huh?
That's what it is, though.
Okay!
What it is!
Not that.
You know, recently, we've been shouting out to ruffians joining us by watching the archive of our streams by sharing with them a special FUWAMOCO word!
Yeah!
Oh, you know it!
What do they do with the FUWAMOCO word?
You can post it in the comments.
Yeah!
But I think maybe that there's some ruffians who don't really
Understand.
Didn't get the message.
Yeah, maybe a little bit lost.
So we wanted to explain that, you know, the FUWAMOCO word is simply just something that you can comment to let us know that you enjoyed the stream after we were live.
And also, you know, it gives a FUWAMOCO, a channel here, a little bit of a boost too.
A little bit of a push.
It gives us a push.
Hi!
We love getting your comments so much, you know.
We understand that you're busy too, so maybe you don't know what to say.
But if you really want to comment something, here you go!
FUWAMOCO!
Hi!
Ruffians, you know, even though
We're just really happy and so thankful to have you here supporting and watching us always.
Yeah, we're always looking to the comments!
Thank you, ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, that was it.
I saw, you know, on a recent stream, there was a ruffian who left a really, really nice long comment.
I was like, okay, it's okay because FUWAMOCO's not gonna see this.
I saw it.
Sometimes there's a lot of you that say, oh it's okay, FUWAMOCO will never see that.
Right!
I'm like, ha!
That's so interesting!
Why would you say that?
Don't think we'll see it, huh?
Why would you think that?
Yeah.
If you say that, we'll see it.
If you don't say that, we'll see it.
Yeah.
Thank you Ruffians!
As for today's FUWAMOCO run, well...
You have to wait, it's not that time yet.
No!
BAU BAU!
As you can see, we have nothing.
Hi!
Ruffians!
Wasn't it the other day we talked about how we had cup noodles for the first time, right?
From Koyori-senpai!
We really liked them!
I know, they're nice and warm on my throat.
Well, we still had a few left, so I had one the other day!
And I... well... There was a problem.
To tell the truth, I haven't been very hungry recently.
So it's been taking me a while to eat things.
I think I was a bit lost in thought while I was eating.
Because I went to place it down on the table.
But I missed.
And my noodles accidentally fell over the floor.
How sad.
All the noodles!
Everywhere!
They looked like they were crying.
The noodles were crying?
The noodles were crying!
You didn't see a reflection of yourself?
No, I did not cry!
I did not cry!
No crying over spilled noodles.
You know, they wanted to be eaten!
And now that dream would never come true!
I felt bad cleaning them up.
I wanted you to help out too.
Yeah, sure.
You know, I just wanted to have warm noodles!
But I'll be more careful with my coordination in the future, okay?
Sorry, noodles!
Sorry, Fuwawa.
I ruined your dreams.
BAU BAU!
How's luck for noodles?
We are fine noodles.
No!
No fire chicken noodles!
It's cup noodles, no.
Before we didn't have them.
Unless there happens to be, like, a bowl-shaped gap in the floor.
That would be a problem.
That's a problem.
Why'd you eat it if you spilt it into a bowl-shaped hole in the floor?
Yeah?
You know what I'm thinking?
Who else would use that hole in the floor?
I can't.
You know how much stuff would get in that hole in the floor?
How much junk?
A lot of fluff and fuzz, yeah.
Extra toppings.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, that was the dirtiest part of the floor.
Right.
Like seaweed.
Oh, it's true, that would be good, you know.
A lot of times the noodles have the seaweed, so extra seaweed, right?
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan.
The week just started, but I feel like it's already been a long week, hasn't it?
Ruffians!
Do you need something?
I need a little push forwards.
It's rough!
BAU BAU!
Well.
Okay.
Ruffians!
Can you believe it?
Somehow, it's already that time of week!
How is it here already?
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
It's been a while, huh?
Have you been good?
Have you been making sure to take care of yourself?
Maybe recently.
No.
You've been working a bit too hard.
I know it's rough.
You get wrapped up in things.
You can't help it!
But sometimes you have to remember to put yourself first before you can help others, okay?
I know.
Things have been rough.
Sometimes I...
You just feel like you spilled your noodles all over the floor.
But don't worry!
You can just clean it up, keep on going, but make sure you count, okay?
You can do it!
I know you can!
Let's have a big battle scream together!
Okay!
Huh?
3, 2, 1!
You don't need to hear it, but... Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Moco-chan, that was quite the scream there.
Together with the Ruffians.
Just make sure to continue getting lots of rest, okay?
I'll try.
BAU BAU!
Another amazing part of the day.
I'm Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today, Hamoco-chan?
Doggie of the Day?
It's me!
That's a beautiful voice!
Look at all the colors!
It's like a marble.
You can kind of see inside Finn's nostrils there, right?
Cute!
It's cute when you can see inside the nostrils, right?
Don't look inside our nostrils, Ruffians.
It actually stands for fluffy and fuzzy.
Fuzzy!
As well for friend!
Friend!
Finn loves to cuddle and get head pats.
And he just wants to be friends with everyone.
The F stands for friend.
Yeah, that's why.
How does Finn BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
I think it's like... BAU BAU!
Oh?
BAU BAU!
Oh, everything's kind of in bubble waters.
So how do I shout see you?
Do it again.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Fin!
Beautiful.
A beautiful, positive, and well-mannered boy that I think is the definition of man's best friend.
You know, look at the cute little head tilt too.
He loves you.
BAU BAU!
Right?
Last year, how would an organized fan
Right in between here, right Moco-chan?
Right there.
BAU BAU!
Next, Ruffians!
You've been keeping those paws moving, right?
Very important to do.
Let's check out where you've been going for walks.
Today I went on a walk.
De-den!
Amazing!
Look at all the fluffy cherry blossom trees there is!
They're in full bloom.
Are they still in full bloom?
It's beautiful.
Right?
That's not fair.
Why?
Why is right?
Right?
So fluffy.
I don't know if you want to walk and walk and walk.
You just never return home, right?
This is my new home.
Right?
This is my road.
It really does look like an anime though.
We hope that you're able to enjoy them lots before they all fell off the tree.
Minecraft's real, right?
Minecraft is real!
I think this is more beautiful.
BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Do you have any comfort anime or manga you usually watch and read when you get sick?
I usually read the same things every time I feel sick because they make me feel better.
I'm glad you have things like that.
We kind of have that, but it's not an anime.
We kind of talked about this show a little bit around the time it debuted, but we really like a TV program that airs in Osaka called Tantei Night School.
It's really funny and heartfelt, and it's a show that's been continuing since the 80s in Japan.
And well, the viewers, they write in like scoops for the comedians.
Cases.
Cases?
Yeah.
Yeah, but the comedians, they're the detectives.
And they have to crack the case.
Yeah.
Figure out the scoops.
You know, sometimes it's things like, where does my dog go?
Why are they so fat?
You know, why does my egg explode when I put it in the microwave?
I want to eat waffles with a manhole cover design.
Please help me.
Stuff like that.
It's a bit chilly.
It's just really so funny and cute and I feel like it shows so many of the things that we really love about Japan.
It's all wrapped up in one show.
So you know, we're really
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
I feel it!
It's good when Nishida Kyokujo cries.
Yeah!
She's like, ahhh!
And then I'm crying too.
Yeah, the... the detectable?
Yeah, the boss?
Yeah.
But I really hope that maybe one day they'll release- Oh my- Netflix or something!
In English and then everyone can enjoy it, you know?
It's such a good show, it's so good.
It's a shame it hasn't been released in English yet.
We're waiting.
Waiting!
BAU BAU!
Thank you again, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for your submissions.
Ruffians!
Have you ever wanted to be a FUWAMOCO Morning?
If so, go to Twitter.
Use that hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Share your work with us.
You know,
Your Doggie of the Day.
Maybe you have a question.
Maybe you saw Pero.
I thought maybe.
You can be also have a good morning!
Don't forget.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Well next we have
An upcoming stream, right Moco-chan?
I have an upcoming stream.
I'm playing Touhou!
Touhou Fujinoku Mountain of Fate.
I know Moco-chan, you played it a bunch and then Marine-senpai coached you and you got much better.
Here is the controller.
I was there.
I got to hear everything.
I got to see everything.
I learned a lot.
So I wanna practice and hopefully the Marine-senchou-senpai will notice me.
So I hope that you'll be there to help me too, Ruffians.
And watch my first Touhou ever.
BAU BAU!
Next, we take a peek at our schedule.
Well, it's a big weekend coming up for us.
We have our super karaoke party in Taipei.
So we're gonna do our best to hopefully make everyone BAU BAU more than they've ever BAU BAUed before.
BAU BAU meeting!
And then after that, I have my first solo rock n' roll party!
I'm looking forward to it, but I'm really really really nervous.
So I hope that you'll be there to cheer me on, my FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
Are the Taipei things going to be streamed on 4Tune?
I don't think so, no.
They won't be, but... Maybe you have some Ruffian friends that are gonna be going that can let you know just how it was!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Mocomoco might be vertical.
I'm gonna try my best and sing vertical this time.
Sing vertically!
Hopefully not upside down!
I guess I could always try singing horizontally, like lying down, but I don't know if the music will come out of me properly that way, so...
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU for joining us today!
FUWAMOCO!
Here is your FUWAMOCO award!
It's BAU BAU spilled noodles!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
No more spilled noodles, right, Moco-chan?
Hopefully.
Better.
Thank you.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Moco!
BAU BAU!
Weilu!
Porkchop.
BAU BAU!
Root.
Friendly Punk.
BAU BAU!
Musby.
Shion.
BAU BAU!
Winnie.
Gundam Figure.
BAU BAU!
Tori Tomyutomu.
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!